it was a free fair transparent process
from the period of compelling to the
period of the actual voting everybody is
declared the process free peaceful and
transparent being threatened with a
legal challenge from the main opposition
the MDC what do you make of it well in a
democracy people are allowed to say what
they want but when you look to
practicality then one must be objective
and it is true that the campaign was
free hundred and thirty three political
parties which campaigned throughout we
have 55 which residents registered for
actually participating in the election
and they went through their campaigns
very well and we have 23 which
registered for the office of the
president and the camp and freely and
peacefully until we reach the elections
which again was conducted totally freely
and peacefully was a big difference but
even so the [ __ ] central monitor
said it was very quiet there they only
registered a hundred and twenty thousand
votes during the day and yet suddenly
there were three hundred and twenty
thousand between the time of 5:00 and
7:00 p.m.
I wondered just how concerned you are
about these continued rumblings from not
just the MDC but some of the civil
society organizations but with those who
have their complaints and so on
fortunately our Constitution is very
clear if you have any threats or any
doubt about anything which you think was
not done according to the law often due
to the Constitution of the Republic the
cuts are open also at every election
consume provides that the judiciary
should do set aside the specific
electric cuts in each province for
purposes of dealing with such issues as
expeditiously as is possible
I wondered to reach out to those every
good leader always reach out to those
who have not supported Jim so that your
margins increase I am saying the
politics should now take the backseat
because the elections are behind us we
should now put our shoulders to the
wheel for purposes of modernizing our
economy growing our economy together
those who are fighting against me those
who voted for me we say Zimbabwe is ours
together let's move on the best argument
the best vision the best ideas have
taken are today not only that Motor
Vehicles I think you've seen it were
bent many Motor Vehicles event
Robert was destroyed not very me but you
saw that yes but we'll get that some
people died
this is why I'm instituting a commission
of inquiry to precisely find out who did
what and we publish that for our
citizens to know who did wrong would not
do wrong I have placed my nation that I
am going to suit a commission of inquiry
immediately after my inauguration in
1964 Harold Wilson of Britain did one
sit between the conservative by one seat
and they formed the government they
ruled England and I have to test
majority and they are talking about knee
high burden in my students majority into
thinking government of national unity
nor that is a great idea but it doesn't
show that there's any need many people
wanted me in responded to be in good
books unfortunately they'll dream any
dream in it's not no one can build a
draw against dreams let those people
continue to dream me and my brother are
friends not only now but throughout the
liberation war total total control if he
is an area I think I'm not in control
can you tell me so I corrected because
I'm satisfied I am in full control of
the Zimbabwe defense no no the events I
don't think anybody plant those events I
don't end with the plant this unfolded
as a result of the state of the
situation at the time but then I was out
that there was a refugee a poor a jumper
still revered by many people in Zimbabwe
for being an independence leader of the
country what's your relationship now and
what we worry is leading up to that make
sure you do you say
prefect ways with my former president
and former boss
and is the founding father of our
country that no one can change and your
relationship with him now until recently
when you say did not one to vote for me
I didn't think you'd reach that stage of
go to vote was there's nothing wrong I
have done to him but he is this
democratic right to chooses to woo me
votes for I have no problem with the
president Meramec totally when I phone
him and we discuss with this know
perfectly and I always said that I will
obey the Constitution to the letter the
spirit of the caution to the letter i if
I'm Alexa contemned my second Tim better
give me Bob you and enact your nickname
is the crocodile right which sounds
scary I mean they're not many friendly
crocodiles do you feel you've got a
reputation that is feared no no no I'm
is soft as warm
no no I'm very friendly they're going to
ask any one of them they will tell you
that there is a very humble person and
very friendly extremely extremely fair
you can ask them people's leader and
listener listening leader
and humble leader is separately